[Music]  foreign  [Music]  festival and right here actually I'm in  the bar area where fans will be able to  come and buy a Budweiser who has you're  a major sponsor of FIFA they have an  agreement for exclusive sale of beer  during the World Cup now this was all  part of an alcohol policy that was  agreed between the country organizers of  the World Cup and FIFA but now just two  days to go FIFA has reversed that policy  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  tickets to travel here some of them  already on the plane some of those some  of them had expectations about where  they would be able to buy beer on game  days but I've also spoken to other  locals here who say that they're happy  that Qatar has held to its religious  positions that priority has been given  to Islamic culture and values  foreign  [Music]